We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. now
this voicemail I'm going to play for you.
I actually have received a lot of emails about
this.
This is the only voicemail I've received about
this, but I have received a lot of emails
about the locations from which some of our
recent guests have been appearing on the David
Pakman show.
Take a listen to this.
Hello David.
I was just calling to say that lately I've
seen a few videos where people are in their
bedroom, you can see their dresser, you can
see part of their bed, whatever.
It kind of, I kind of really don't like it.
I feel like I'm in the same room with their
dirty laundry and it's just so not classy.
A piece of plywood, a curtain, anything but
your bedroom where your dirty laundry is.
To me that just screams unprofessional check.
Anyways, that's all.
I just a shout out to all the bedroom YouTubers,
please stop it.
Thank you.
Yeah, so I, when I first heard this voicemail,
I thought that they were talking about some
of our guests.
When I, when we connect, they're in their
bedroom and it's sort of like, listen, if
that's where they're set up for the interview,
we're going to do it.
And I get a lot of emails for, particularly
from our viewers in Europe who say, you know,
David, I don't know if it's different in the
United States, but in Europe the bedroom is
considered sort of a private place where you
wouldn't do like a national interview for
radio and television and online media from
your bedroom where you see your bed.
And it's sort of surprising.
Is this common for Americans?
This particular color seems to be referring
more to YouTube or who do content from their
bedrooms.
Now, I can't think of any that do that.
I don't really watch anything, as I've said
before, but I don't know of anybody.
I mean, I've seen it.
I know Sam Cedar has a set because I obviously
stole his intellectual property to make my
set.
So I know he's got a set.
Um, I don't know who else is, is shooting
in their bedroom or whatever, but is this
something people care about?
I want to hear from you.
What about the bedroom scenes that are appearing
increasingly on the David Pakman show, uh,
for guests and on YouTube?
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the passing of John Conyers,
the longest serving black congressmen who
has passed away at age 90.
We will talk about Lyft offering free rides
to job interviews, and we will talk about
Betsy Devoss being held in contempt of court
for enforcing
loans on defrauded college students.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show become a member or a patron to get instant.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].